- Je rate jamais maintenant.
- C'est l'CCCCCCCCCCCCCCCCCCCCÇ.
- Marilyn Castonguay, vous êtes
Huguette, la caïd de Sainte-Foy
dans la série "C'est comme ça
qu
question, je me gâte,
comment fait-on pour avoir
l'oeil du tigre?
MARILYN CASTONGUAY, comédienne
Tu fais ça sans arrêt chez vous
devant le miroir.
- Est-ce que c'est
ce que vous avez fait?
- Non. Mais non. Bien, l'oeil
du tigre, c'est un concept,
t'sais, en m
que c'était plus à l'image,
puis un effet de caméra
qu'on voulait... une intensitéms
que moi-même. T'sais, moi,
il fallait juste que je joue
puis que j'aile dansononononono.
Mais là, elle a un autre
cette année.
- Oui?
c'est le tigre; puis, le gauche,
t t t t d'autre chose.
- Il a raison,
c'est cette année. a a a a a a e
oeil. Parlons justementde la de.
Comment vous avez préparé
votre personnage?, , , , , , , e
le corps. T'sais, ce n'est plus
le même corps. Là, elle était
enceinte. Fait que c'est comme
si je retrouenenenenenenenenenet
que je retrouve quand même
s s s s repères clés
de ce personnage-là.
ce que vous voulez,
mais je veux ces gars-là morts!
Mais en même temps,
je pense qu'on a réussi
justement à l'amener,
à l'amener où les gens vont
pouvoir quand même s'attac
à elle.
♪ ♪ ♪
"C'est comme ça que je t'aime",
mais vous faites
les enfants, depuis plusieurs
années, dans des séries
à "1, 2, 3... Géant",
"Salmi " " " " "Alix
et les merveilleux".
Où trouvez-vous votre bonheur
- Bien, c'est une liberté
lelelelele! Une série jeunesse,
j'ai l'impression que tu crées
une famille, de prime abord,
le temps, puis c'est quotidien.
Puis, fait que tu arrives là,
puis tu es comme chez vous.c'c',
t t t t t de la folie. En même
temps, c'est quelque chose
très difficile et demandantausss
mentir aux enfants. Tu peux pas
comme être... parC'C'C'C'C'C'C'e
chose de très vif, puis très...
très franc comme approche.
Fait que j'ai l'impression que
si tu es n n n n n n n n n n n s
tout de suite, en fait,
que tu es plus ou moins
à la bonne place. Puis,
d'une génération, puis
quand tu te vois dans
les yeux des enfants,
ils te reconnaisse
d'admiration qu'ils ont,
puis le bonheur qu'ils ont
à te regard
de prix, vraiment.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Retour en arrière. Vous avez
auauauauauauauauauauauauauauauar
comédienne et d'aller
à l'École nationale de théâtre.
Pourquoi ce changement
et ensuite théâtre?
- Bien, la danse, oui, c
vraiment mon grand rêve
de danser. Puis, après ça, bien,
des limites aussi. T'sais,
s s s s s s s limites corporell,
des maux de dos qui ont fait
était un petit peu plusicicicica
peut-être une petite rigueur
vingtaine, après mon cégep.T'sap
quel genre de danse, puis quel
fait que j'ai comme pris une
pause, puis je me suis entraînée
ici, à Montréal. C'est ce qui
en fait. Mais j'avais toujours
fait du théâtre aussi.
Puis, cette rigueur-là peut-être
peu perdue puis que mon corps
m'empêchait aussi d'avoir
a fait en sorte que j'ai
qui était le jeu,
puis ça a vraiment marché.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Depuis votre sortie de l'École
nationale de théâtre en 2010,
défis. Un de vos plus récents,
je croislololololololololo
de près de deux heures
au théâtre intitulé "Les filles
une mère de deux enfants.
vevevevevevevevevez vécu
cette expérience?
- Bien, au début, c'était trè
pas être capable de releveréféfe
seule devant ces gens-là.
Mais, t'sais, on est
T'sais, je suis pas unique,je s,
je suis pas la plus...
Mais c'est ls,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,
très sensible et délicat.
Puis, c'est quelque chose...
C'est comme une espèouououououo.
D'avoir fait ce proj
amenée complètement ailleurs
et dans ma façeteteteteteteteter
les chosese e e e e e e e e e s,
tous ces gens-là qui ont été
touchés
femme-là, à ce point-là, ça,
ça r r r r r r r r r réussite.
- Marilyn Castonguay, alias
de garder l'oeil du tigre.
Merci beaucoup.
une chose, mon mari ad
Je ne peux pas m'occuper
et, en plus, dirig
une organisation criminelle.
C'est un ou l'autre.
- En plus que,
le bacon dans la maison.
- Regardle
pas de ses affaires, lui.
- Bonne jo